jo-ann's weight loss was on track to be
life-changing but nearly 30 stone she
managed to lose five after joining a
specialist clinic but funding for the
service was cut along with many of her
hopes how much does your weight affect
it's your life as a 37 year old every
day I have children because of my way
since losing the support and therapy
Joann has regained weight and lost
confidence I don't want to do something
about and I know I can but it's mentally
it upset you
sounds like words have hurt your lot in
the past yeah yeah people can be cruel
for Juwan now having to go to a
mainstream gym is intimidating speaking
to doctors who don't know her sometimes
upsetting the first thing you said was I
am going to need to mention straightaway
that you are morbidly obese so I didn't
I didn't really say anything cuz I had
never noticed and then he said to me you
37 I said yeah he said to me yeah either
lose weight now or don't bother I never
really reacted
why are you Marbley obese I said because
you know it's something that's happened
over a long time you know a mental
health issue was and it kind of like
sort of sniggered at that and then he
said well to be honest I'm surprised
you're not dead already
this is the help Joann can no longer
access at the rather I'm Institute for
obesity it's treatment is now only
available to privately pay patients but
its value is clear how's your life
changed
when I'm 16 I don't think squeeze these
men have lost 31 stone between them
Wayne has shed 14 of them through the
help of the clinic his old trousers help
paint the picture of his progress my
diabetes went into remission and I was
one of the lucky few that went through
the system it is a life changer rather
am now lacks in funding it makes up for
in fast food like many deprived areas in
brother it makes up well over half of
the town's options for eating out the
link between fast food restaurants and
obesity levels is well known and here
too in every three adults are classified
as either overweight or obese dr. Matz
Cape Horn helped people in Rotherham
shed 33 metric tonnes over eight years
he says the funding cut at clinics
around the country would only end up
costing the NHS we see patients every
day that need a service like this so
it's very frustrating as an NHS doctor
that now I can't help those patients we
know that within one generation obesity
the direct and indirect costs could
potentially bankrupt the NHS because the
projections are they it will cost 50
billion pounds a year and this was a
service that only cost 300 thousand
pound a year to run the Department of
Health those there's more than 200,000
people every year across England will
have access to targeted weight-loss
support and advice no matter how much
supports out there
it's really only down to you yeah that's
quite right it is only down to me but I
don't think Kelly one couldn't succeed
yeah without support you know I don't
want people sympathy it's just I wish
people had more empathy because they
don't know mastering they've not walked
in my shoes
kindness isn't prescribed but that costs
nothing
Sally Lockwood Sky News rather him